thank you for education that allows us
to spend some conversation of kind of in
a more intimate conversation and
something about passion
classical music national music
traditional music the all kinds of names
for it mu serious vanity and with a
great performer and a great scholar of
passion music as we witnessed before
lunch I think perhaps the first question
that comes to my mind with reference to
passion music is that how this tradition
of music has in the over the past
hundred 50 years or 200 years has
evolved we have this concept of task
some of us more familiar from the 1950s
60s and so on and then the concept of
relief that also was introduced at least
to my recollection slightly later and
the differentiation between the last
command that if somewhat perhaps in the
minds of many people myself is that very
clear actually a good starting point if
you would say a few words about the
differentiation between the distinction
between the two thank you very much
I should tell that I have been
preoccupied with this object in the past
few years and I actually try to look to
look at the early development of the
DASCO system the term DASCO goes back to
the mid a
in century I wasn't able to find any
reference to that prior to that time and
we know that up to the end of the
Safavid period which means seventeen
twenty thirty the model system of
persian music was based on mahom and
shot there which was very much similar
to what we have in persian music right
now but twenty middle of the seventeenth
eighteenth century we know that you know
the situation in Iran was very chaotic
in a sense you know the alphonse invaded
and the Safavid you know empire lost its
centrality and as a result of that a lot
of court musicians actually left the
court and they moved to other cities and
that you know poor music center court
music was no longer you know was no
longer in Iran and during the Afghan and
after our period we don't see much of a
court you know tradition not a show for
example had a lot of musicians in his
camp but there's no evidence that he had
you know any of those Safavid court
musicians anyhow you know and then we
see that the term mark arm
gradually is replaced by of us so a lot
of people would call these my mom's you
know our Wars toward the end of the 18th
century and so there were different
roses you know and each had a proper
name and some of them were you know a
loose version of Safavid Mahal some of
them were brand new dr melody types folk
right melody types some of them were
compositions you know and most from
neighboring traditions so I think that
again in the middle and in the beginning
of the 19th century this musical figure
at the court of Fateh Ali Shah put
certain our waters together and made
these - cough okay and he came up with
12 sequences of - cause that it's not
that they follow the same structure the
same formula know the mood or behavior
in each task is different and a lot of
people especially later music theorists
would say that it's a matter of taste
how to put these hours together and yeah
so he came up with these 12 - a scores
but I should tell you that the two of
the Oscars that he came up with were
completely different from those that we
see in the rediff in music - loss relief
there were other traditions at the same
time we know that mama saw the horn had
a completely different arrangement of
the Oscars in that time he even had some
- cause that were not really called
DASCO in the ready for observe the law
in the repertoire of musical law so
there were different tradition is for
the sake of clarity the - persistence
miserable no it was much later almost
late
music doula and Mohammad saw the Honda's
2-quart musical figures were
contemporary they lived at the same time
and they follow two different traditions
yeah so who's even nowadays of the 12 7
of them are usually called desk oh yes
another five we call our Center - so
where does that it fits into this well
to the best of my knowledge the term
relief starts with me is Abdullah there
is no reference to this term prior to
miss out the law so I think that it was
coined by him and is this some kind of
emphasis on the idea that how this who
shared that should be played within a
desk oh is that what relief is all about
yes yes well first of all I should tell
you that you know it's not that everyone
in the 19th century played the same you
know there was no common music
repertoire which was shared by all
musicians no that was not the case
everybody tried to collect his own
pieces and put them together and make
his own repertoire and they inherited
you know some of the is some part of
this repertoire from their breath you
know yes and and at the same time where
they were very defensive and secretive
about this knowledge they wouldn't you
know give it to other people and it was
always within the family and their idea
was something that King mr. Abdullah
inherited from his father and his
his cousin yes and this repertoire we
know that was in their family at least
four brah
two generations and that's what is
really a standardized yes we today that
if basically means repertoire and the
genius of the relief of music the law
was the clocking system that he probably
inherited from his father the idea of
the GU share actually goes back to the
late 16th century really yes late 16th
century there is there's a perm usik
theorists in Harad in the 1680 who was
at the court of animal han-shan do was
lale of a buzzer yes and in his musical
treatise he says that the term who share
originated in enforce and our origin in
those regions yeah so we of course some
people would say that's not even
standardized either because some people
say that in the current system there are
188 pushes that's wrong would say it's
more than say yes it's a matter of
interpretation it's a matter of
interpretation and it's a matter of
musical knowledge you know you know I've
heard people saying that you know he had
a very limited ready that means his
repertoire his the number of gooses in
his repertoire is very limited yeah but
music the law obviously collected all
the melody types that were known to him
at that time and he came up with this
you know repository of lucious
yes before we go any further and
actually focus more on the instruments
and your performance thanks one more
question that the service in my mind
there is all these treaties there's
always attention through the actual
theory of music at the same time that
all all this sis for every Stein were
always written how come dance to
notation system was ever developed in
Iran or any attempt was made to shift
from this kind of heart to heart and
memorization of the music to some kind
of a notation well at 30 unless there
was a musical notation in the 14 and 15
century but the purpose of notation was
obviously different it was not for
educational purposes they just wanted to
record you know a melodic figure for
example or you know a very short you
know piece of music they believed that
music has to be transmitted orally yeah
yes and there were certain ideas and
certain discourses around music that was
also transmitted through you know
teacher and pupil mm-hmm which I would
imagine is a very kind of goofy idea
that in a say yes in the environment
about yes that's the master pupil kind
of relationship that requires the kind
of presence that's right
rather than reading from that's right
and one more thing that I want to add to
your last question is that why music
Darla came up with this idea of ready he
was a pedagogue in essence and as
opposed to his other colleagues who were
improvisers who were just performers
he was not a high-caliber musician miss
Angela and he had a very limited
technique of tour you know in her memoir
torture sat and I would say that you
know I was supposed to study with music
Luda he came back and taught me for a
few sessions and after one or two years
I could play the tour better than this
you know who tend to man that's what she
says
anyhow
he was not a very you know professional
musician he was a professional musician
but he didn't have their chosen yeah so
he came up with this relief and he had
to fix this you know whooshes he had to
fix he had to come up with a fixed
version of these melodies in order to be
able to teach it to his students
otherwise you wouldn't have been able to
do it you know you can't teach something
to your student and next time you change
it you know
you have to have as frozen a fix that
you know version of your melodies to be
able to do it so this is what happened
we had one that soon came about that the
time when music comes out of the private
space into an environment where the
between pupils who would like to
actually learn music that's right
exactly prior to him music was not
really accessible to everybody I said
you know people these you know top
musicians at the course were very
secretive and protective of their own
repertoire they wouldn't listen she yes
post Constitution
that opens up this place for the music
now going back to but more towards your
twisting instrumental instruments and
the history of instruments
I suppose miserable as many students
were cetera visited his maintenance to
impose a third although the history of
sitar goes back a long time and it's
kind of a very central this long neck
Newt has been known in Iran for many
centuries and the generic term for this
instrument is Tambu and sometimes it had
two strings sometimes he had three
strings and sometimes and had four
strings
you know and sometimes you know that the
the instrument becomes known by the
number of strings that it has for
example a guitar is obviously a Tambu
which has two strings or set R is that
no is a type of Tambor which has only
three strings so this will do it fourth
one was added to it with more stuff
that's right that's right as the great
Sufi but you know they kept it
[Music]
I presume the most significant indicator
of any desk oh yes
Donna Maude is the opening piece of each
task and in a sense a person who starts
a - God always has to start with a
diorama in which you you introduced the
first mode in each task and you start to
unfold it you know little by little
throughout the diorama and elaborate
upon melodic elements of the diorama and
once the dharam art which is by itself
and of ours is fully developed and foody
unfolded then you modulate to the next
hours and once you you know elaborate on
the next hours and then you can modulate
on the third hours so in a sense you
know all of us is a largest segment and
within two hours you have three or four
or five gushes okay
for example in the first of all which is
always called diorama
I'm going to play model
[Music]
and then the next coucher cherish man
this coucher is said to a line of poetry
his own remarkable Papa as on labeija
Karina
so as you see I play the dorama first
and then I started to develop within the
melodic confines of the da Ramat by
playing the Karishma this is one of the
ways that you can always develop a
Gousha playing a character in it as a as
a matter of fact if you go throughout
the relief of Musa of the law you see
crash mare in many instances okay or
visit mode no can do it can be anywhere
it can be anywhere so I'm saying that
karishma's usually played just to
elaborate upon the melodic elements of a
Gousha this is how Gousha is melodically
developed can i yes I play
[Music]
this is shoe
[Music]
once you finish the data mod then you
can play the good cash man
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so let's go back to Maho once you finish
the first of us
the second of ours is a modulation so
you modulate to another of us and the
second hour was the tonal center is
different
so the tonic in the first thought was
was though whereas in the second hours
is
Peconic was see get easy
[Applause]
within these hours you can play a series
of bushings
even it kiddush man
[Music]
now the third of Oz is Haram
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the tonic center is different see and
you can also play the kiddush media
[Music]
and you usually go back to the first
hours to punctuate different segments of
the - go
[Music]
you
at all
[Music]
so now I am going to play the cash man
[Music]
through it again tomorrow
[Music]
and the concept of NASCAR is completed
when you play toss leaf and rank at the
end of these are wowzers so in a sense
that's God was a concert format which
started with Dara mod and series of our
voices and at last at a sneef and
ringlets perform this complete format
was called DASCO all the time but in the
20th century you know all these segments
were referred to as Gousha
okay there are still some you know
master musicians who try to mark you
know certain sections as always and
certain you know pieces as cliche but
ordinary musicians you know just call
everything couchette and sometimes you
know Dara mod is called the DASCO which
is not correct the whole structure the
whole you know ordered structure is
called - God can you give us an example
because this this book tell us a little
bit about what's the matter child funny
and when I have novel Z's
when you move from one task to another
dashboard and this is of course a
special skill associated
and how how that it's done well maracas
honey or Moroccan Ozzy is when you
modulate to a distant almost or distant
- God you know even more ICAP means
modulation you have a module Ettore
scheme
it's called Mo Rocca and DASCO itself is
a mana cap but in the discard structure
you always modulate too near you know
all wowsers but once you modulate too
distant our losses then it requires a
very complicated technique that you have
to you know develop it's not something
that you can do it you know on your own
it takes a lot of practice and yeah so
maracas vanna vazhi in a sense is
modulation from one task or to another
and maybe you have a series of you know
- cause and you can modulate from one to
another
this is called more I can - is usually
the entry from that's right that's right
which is part of this part that's right
[Music]
I have to add that in the School of
Music the law more like a Pawnee - more
like having a sense that you modulate
from one task to another - God is not
acceptable because they would say that
if a musician modulates from one - go to
another that means that his in a
repertoire of bushes in one - door was
limited so he had to you know move to
another task but once you know the whole
structure of the DASCO and all the
bushes then you try to modulate within
the task rather than you know modulating
to another task oh I presume and
considered as the height of musical
skill that any musical knowledge able to
move on to the other and assist and not
only from one task to another with
several - girls say we call shaggy
Aryans versus famous piece on Naboo
- that's a masterpiece that semester is
not that anyone can do such a thing
yes
then of course we hear but you pointed
out the ring and the TAS leave that's
right but something which is very
popular at this in the 20th century is
this charm is rod which becomes very
much part of this repertoire that's in
each dance girl network
Felicia's mastery becomes part of the
repertoire how these were introduced at
how much they have artists in order to
give a greater variety to the music yeah
well charm is Rob was basically have a
composition which was developed on the
sandwich yes and I have to tell you that
musicians of different musical
instruments had different repertoires in
the Pajar period in the 19th century and
you know Sharma's rob was one of the
specialities of san tool players when we
look at the charmers robes that were
played on the sitar
[Music]
half-charred mezrab form is robbed
[Music]
one two three four
[Music]
this is an early charmers job which was
played this is the charm is driving that
it moves up to Allah but later on in the
hands of Darvish horn and I will Hassani
Sabbah charmers Rob developed and became
a very sophisticated musical
compositions the famous charm is Rob
composed by a dervish horn
[Music]
in China's Rob you have a section which
is called ritornello in English which
serves as a point of reference you
compose around this section you move to
different you know areas of melodic
range and ultimately you come back and
punctuate you know different sections of
genres Rob with this particular section
which was called in the 19th century
para poner but it's not common anymore
to in
[Music]
okay now obviously an important question
is the question of improvisation what
you've just described or simply to us
that there is a set of arses and who she
is that's right that you have to play so
how does it this corresponds to
improvisation as people to the provides
Asian in the West particularly is a jazz
improvisation what extent the
improvisation and personal traditional
music is really a very free performance
is it something that this always object
to certain discipline yes well free
improvisation is not really acceptable
to traditional musicians you know I
remember that my my own teacher would
criticize some improvisers as doing
vagabond dodge on the notes you know you
play something but you it's so scattered
minded and you really don't know what
you're doing you know so in order to be
able to improvise you need to have some
melodic ideas and what are these melodic
ideas you know each Gousha has certain
melodic phrases characteristic phrases
so you need to know these characteristic
phrases to understand what the structure
of each Gousha is and based on those
characteristics phrases then can play
around and come up with your own you
know creative input and you know play
with these phrases and you know
improvise upon them so you need to know
the structure of each Gousha first and
based on the structure then you can
add your own you know input and do you
think that this is more of a conscious
effort or is it something that it's
internalized and really comes out of
your heart well you know the thing is
that unfortunately people become Kenny
Shea after a while
so it's not that you know every time you
play a Gousha you come up with something
completely new you know so people
usually develop their own you know
version of each you know melody and most
of the time they've played the same and
it's very hard to come up with you know
new ideas every time that you play music
but sometimes the you come across some
people who have this you know ability
and yeah questions I've seen do you have
anything to inaccurately say this is
another sitar player sitting there I
have to ask you what do you think so if
you have any questions or comments
you refer to modulation as the
transition from one allotted patterns to
another in the water having typically in
the same that stuff in music music of
the region the phrases the materially
shorter for them a lot of patterns at
the end of plane and that offers a wider
array a wider vocabulary of the
transition from place to place the place
there's been arguments and suggestions
that in naive one of the things that we
have done in organizing Alicia is is
that by not shortening that Lucia is
substantially more so that we're left
with only the for the bomb or the four
notes or the five notes that are
relevant by not doing that we sort of
hamstring the musician and not being
able to move fast enough or modulate
fast enough from place to place
do you give any credence to that benefit
I didn't get what she said can you
elaborate on that in the traditions of
for example in our only music and
generally in our music the melodic
patterns have been reduced substantially
more than what we have in who shares in
yuan so in Iran when you play we show
the examples that you've demonstrated
the melodic pattern is substantially
longer is that would be mandated by the
rhythm that comes from the poetry that
you bring into the piece in our music
typically you don't have that music you
cannot really reduce the melodic phrases
of a Gousha to just the scale to their
own scale you know so besides the beside
the scale a Gousha is characterized with
you know certain phrases and in order to
show the real characteristic of a Gousha
you need to you know play those notes
that constitute the opening note the
finale's focus on those and dispense
this fence would initiate in some sense
because in some sense that we share was
a pneumonic for the student to learn the
structure if the structure is
fundamental is something that but the
different ways of looking at you know
the structure of a Gousha of course you
know some people would look at it as a
mnemonic you know pattern yeah but for
some people who share has a structure
and you know the whole structure Brown
is what makes that coucher you know you
cannot reduce it you cannot you know
eliminate certain figures that's what I
think but maybe a good segue to ask this
question is this you know we witnessed
in the middle of the twentieth century
this kind of a movement toward a more
purest kind of music perhaps part of it
the response to the world how part of
its response to the introduction of
piano and the violin into the Persian
music and all of that this is cool it's
a fad and the others to try to move back
to what they consider spurious music
what's your position on that because I
think it corresponds to the fact that if
there were attempts to try to draw them
the range of the person music
they don't know and then try to return
to this kind of a more supposedly more
pure music fashion music where is your
where do you stand on that well I would
say that people have always looked at
this subject from different perspectives
and you know they were some people who
were very purist and there were some
people who were not you know that period
and they were not really concerned about
the showing the structure of a Gousha
and their improvisation was you know so
I have my own preference but I guess
sometimes in nineteen seventies with the
establishment of mark as if that was one
of the major movements that was behind
this you know traditional music and that
and the word traditional was something
it was imported you know from from
friends one day mr. P would have
referred to the music of good as
tradition that's
let's see I see that's the wood exceeds
the same thing don't you think yes I see
this also is an attempt to try to purify
music from what it was referred as moved
as I this kind of trivial music now it
has been purified you you you basically
use this time when you think that what
you have is in danger we have coffee
I just and then we meet back here again
and for 15 thank you thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]